well first I want to say I'm halfway
through season three uh and very curious
how this is all going to work out I'll
say it like that uh but I like throwing
a curve before I get into Jack Ryan
um if for both of you if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
done before uh what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why
I I don't know it's a um
it's a German film I would say
um actually two is the last one my
little sister I think is a is a is a
film that I would love people to see and
um Phoenix maybe that's a another film
I've done
both in the German language but with
subtitles
gosh that's a tough one I mean probably
the obvious answer is get out
because it's such a great film I think
that first and foremost if they if no
one's seen it at this point I'd be like
well you have to see it immediately
um yeah it's such a profound piece of
work that no one should miss out on I'm
still curious when you're filming Jack
Ryan season three you you couldn't have
known how the real world was going to be
when the season comes out but it does
feel like it's very relevant to what's
going on in today's Politics the season
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of it I think it's it's quite eerie and
unsettling to see
the real world emulate what this very
fictional tale is that was written and
created before that it's it's it's so
bizarre and it's
um it's really unsettling and upsetting
and I'm repeating myself I don't know I
it's hard it's hard but at the same time
when you then get to watch it things are
very different
on the other hand than from what's going
on in the real world right now and you
might think you know who the villain is
and then it's not what do you who you
think it is you know so that is that is
the the good thing why I think you can
watch it
with a certain light-heartedness also
and immerse yourself into this Jack Ryan
Universe because the the storyline
is very close to what's happening right
now and the danger that came from all of
this but it's it
comes from a different spot you know
it's it's a different thing on its on
its own and the the good thing I think
for us was that we were shooting it
where none of this was on the horizon
you know maybe for some you know who
knew a bit more but but for the for the
Normal public audience that we didn't
know you know so um we had a certain
light-heartedness and freedom with with
the whole um story while working on it
yeah for both of you um I'm so curious
what because you you haven't been on uh
Jack Ryan before I'm just curious what
it was like behind the scenes that was
um what makes this show a little bit
unique or what was surprising to you
about making Jack Ryan that you perhaps
weren't expecting well I wasn't
expecting the scale of things I mean
it's a big show you know and that you
yeah like you said you fly in fly out
with a jet you know you I mean I didn't
get to fly but to enter the chat
[Laughter]
no I just a friend of you know as the
president of czechia in front of your
whole military gang and holding a speech
you know and trying I mean and then
they're all there you know it's a
it's not being how do you call it CGI
yeah so you know it's it's just real
that that was fast on the scales of the
stages we were working in and you know
you would work for walk from the Oval
Office and to the Czech Republic all of
the office and to the gravel the same
and they really look like it you know
it's like
um that that was just amazing yeah yeah
and I think it's even more so this
season like it's just off the charts how
epic and the stunts Jack does and whoa
It's you're just in the intensity of the
some of those sequences it's just wow
it's it's really great I'm so honored to
be a part of it
I think that's one of the reasons uh
also filming on location that y
resonates with so many people because it
feels when you're watching it like this
is believable you know you're not
watching it like in some small Sound
Stage filming in L.A it's true I think
that is really the appeal of the show
that you you can rely on if Jack and
Mike uh running through the streets of
Athens that's where they are you know
that's really where where the show goes
so yeah
exactly because the show films on
location
um which was the locations that you wish
you could have spent more time in you
know the one that you're like oh this is
amazing I can't believe I'm getting paid
to be here
yeah and uh I mean because it's this
city that feels like it's floating in
the clouds it's so beautiful and I
really only got to spend half a day
there
um but yeah it's it's gorgeous and
really
beautiful castles and Beethoven in the
air you know it's just a very classical
beautiful
aristocratic place
yeah my main time was been in in
Budapest really
um and then being in Prague which was
really where my character comes from and
where she's situated so I would have
loved to spend a little bit more time in
in Prague just to get you know soak it
all in where this character comes from
and just because I love Prague not that
I didn't like Budapest but my God spend
more time there so
yeah it was but it was great though yeah
my last thing real fast and I hate
asking a little bit of a generic thing
but what have you been telling your
friends and family about who you play in
the series
I didn't say anything
because I don't want to spoil anything I
just watch it please
you'll be surprised yeah yeah yeah I
haven't really talked much about it with
my my friends and family I guess that
doesn't mean we're very close then
I'm just they'll see it when they see it
I I don't yeah it's Sam I don't want to
spoil it yeah on that note I'm just
going to say congrats and I'm looking
forward to seeing the last four episodes
thank you oh yes have fun